Alright guys, let's roll the
cameras.    We
are 1318 and
we are   facing
the prospect of stronger opposition.
I'm pretty sure I'm going to have the black
pieces this time. Let's jump in another
15 plus ten speedrun game
today.
Okay, we're
playing in 1163.
So a slightly weaker opponent, but there's
nothing wrong with that and that doesn't
mean we can't play an instructive game.
So we start the game with a
Sicilian as we've done thus far
in the speedrun.   And
at this level we're probably not going to
face   an open Sicilian. We're very
likely to face kind of the Italian
against the Sicilian bishop C Four
or Bishop B Five or one of those
offbeat Sicilians. But we continue
down the main path with Knight to
C Six initiating the accelerated
dragon. In the event of D Four,
we take it and play G Six. And as
predicted, White plays the move.
Bishop, C four. Now, the reason this move
is so popular at ah,
sort of post beginner level
is largely because players don't study the
Sicilian and they kind of default to the
moves that they make against E five. So if
you play the Italian against E Five, you're
likely to play the same moves against the
Sicilian. And the reason that Bishop
C Four is ineffective
against this particular
setup is very simple and it can be
encapsulated in one
word. And that word is well, two words e
Six.   Right?
The reason you don't put the Bishop on C
Four here is because E Six
blunts the Bishop. And then
later on D Five could come with tempo. But
d five isn't
altogether necessary.
What's important is to realize that E Six
completely blunts the Bishop and makes it
look kind of dumb. So
we start by playing E Six.
Now. Can you play G six? Here.
Can you play this like you would an
accelerated dragon? Absolutely nothing
wrong with the move G Six,
but we're going to play this very
thematically. And again, I'm trying to be
as principled as possible. I'm trying to
really punish bad opening
play as much as possible. White play is the
move. C three. Okay? So this is kind of a
souped up elephant.
I'm assuming that our opponent is
preparing D Four.   And
here we have   a
million ways that we can handle
this position. If we want to try
to squeeze the most out
of our,   uh, if we want
to really punish White fully
for playing bishop C Four,
it makes sense for us to play the move
D Five here and occupy
some of the center, especially because
that move occurs with tempo. An
interesting alternative would be to
start with night F six. But the
drawback of playing night F Six is that E
Five is a tad
bit annoying. Right? E Five forces
the night off of F Six and the knight could
jump, for example, to G Four.
But then White attaches
the pawns together with d Four, and we get
into this kind of weird, concrete
struggle that there is absolutely no
reason to engage in if we're playing black.
So the position is not better for black.
We're not better here, but, uh, we
equalize very, very easily
after the straightforward move, D
Five, which we're going to play,
and we can pre move E takes D Five.
But I'm trying to avoid pre moves in the
speed run.
Yeah. So d five is very
straightforward. We are getting control
of the center and doing it with tempo.
So our opponent's
sinking into a bit of a sink here.
And of course, white is
not strictly forced to play
65, but there are no
viable alternatives. There we go.
We have an exchange of pawns in the center.
And here, the order of operations is going
to be pretty important. Uh, in what order do
we develop our minor pieces and where do we
put them? I think a lot of players actually
struggle,  uh, with these types of
positions specifically because you've
got three minor pieces to develop.
And it's easy to get overwhelmed
as, uh, to, like, which pieces to
develop first and where they should go,
because they can go to a lot of different
places. Now, we shouldn't make any hard
and fast decisions until we
understand where the bishop is going,
because the placement of the lightskirt
Bishop is going to influence our
development. And there we have it. Bishop B
Three is a case in point. Against other
Bishop moves, we would have been very likely
to deploy the darkskirt Bishop to D
Six and then move in the the
knight to E seven here. We can't do it
in that order because Bishop D
Six simply drops the pawn on D
Five. Right. So you might think,
well, then we should play the move Bishop to
E Seven. But Bishop E Seven is
kind of a weird way to start. I mean,
you're taught to develop knights before
bishops. I don't think there's anything
inherently wrong with Bishop E seven. I just
think it's a lot more natural to start
by developing the G Eight
knight. Now, where should we move it? Well,
that's a pretty obvious question. Night GE
seven makes the least amount of sense of any
development move because it completely
blocks in the dark squid Bishop.
Right. So knight F six
here seems very natural.
And you don't need to
rediscover the wheel in
these types of positions. Just bring your
pieces out and put them on normal squares.
Night f six Bishop e seven
Castles The other Bishop can go out to G
four. I mean,
development is an art in some
ways, but in other ways, it's all about just
like using your common sense. Okay. C
four. And this is, of course, the first
step in the wrong direction for our
opponent. It's a weird move, which I
think, conceptually, our opponent is trying
to contest our control of the center. But in
reality,  um,
he's helping us. And it's an incredibly
weakening move, c four. We can react to this
move in a variety of
ways. I think most of you
are very tempted by the
move D four.    Why
is the move D four tempting?
Well, in general, it's always tempting to
move upon forward.   And
you might notice that D Four takes
away the C three square from White's Knight.
So that's a good thing. And D four is a good
move. But there's also a
serious case to be made here
for taking on C
Four. And you might say, I don't like
this move because it plays into
White's hands and it allows White to
recapture with the Bishop and open up this
diagonal. Well, the diagonal isn't
that important because after we
deploy our dark sword, Bishop and Castle,
is White really going to develop that
much pressure on F seven?
Like, White doesn't have any other pieces
developed. And the good thing about DC is
that it essentially leaves White with a
very weak backward pawn on
D two.   And
with the D file open, it's going
to be easier in the long run. I'm talking,
like, really long run, ten to 15 moves
from now to put more
pressure on the D Two pun. It's going
to be easier for us to do that.
So D Four is a good move
conceptually, but it keeps the center very
closed. And I'm not
necessarily the biggest fan of that,
especially because we're trying to play in
the spirit of the opening. And in the
Sicilian, we like open center positions.
So we're actually going to
make a decision I think a lot of you might
find questionable, and we're going to take
on C Four. But hopefully I've
explained my logic well enough,
and now we're going to bring out the Dark
Squad Bishop. And the reason we bring
out the Dark Squad Bishop is because the top
priority here should be to Castle. Well,
why should the priority be to Castle?
Because if you look at White's development,
white's next two moves are very
likely to be Castle's kingside and then
rookie one check. And we don't want our king
stuck in the center.    Uh,
when that rook moves into E One, we don't
want to have to deal with that. So we've got
Bishop E seven and Bishop D six. From the
perspective of activity,
bishop D Six is the more active developing
square, and we'd see well, but Bishop D
Six allows White to push D Four
and eradicate the weakness. And this is
where you actually just need to calculate.
You need to be familiar with the typical
motif. As it turns out, Bishop D
64 does not work for White,
because if you imagine everything trades
on D four, and then you have Bishop
D Six to B four check,
a very common motif that you
have to be familiar with,
uh, picking up White
screen. So for this reason,
we're going to bring our Bishop out to the
most active possible square,
exploiting the fact that White really
can never play D four, and White
can't play D Four even after they
castle, which is very
important, and for the very same reason. Not
Bishop before check this time. But, of
course, Bishop takes H Two check in the end.
And this is, uh, an incredibly common
blunder at this level. Now, our opponent is
playing well. D Three is a good move.
And   here we need to
basically combine development with
prophylaxis. Right? There's two options here
that I see for Black. The first
option is to develop the Bishop to G
four. Well, I cannot draw the hair bishop
G four. The second option,
a more prophylactic approach, I think
Petrosian would play. The second move
is to play H Six to stop
White's Bishop from coming out to the
equivalent G Five square. And
I really like, h six. I feel like moves
like H six, they really
make it difficult for
newer players to operate when you take
away,   uh,     their
intentions. So let's throw in the move H
six.     Thank you. Mel it
out for prime. We're preventing Bishop G
Five. Now, some of you might, um, be
wondering, are we not worried about a, uh,
sacrifice on H six, right? Are we not
worried that we're weakening the king's
side? Well, the answer is no,
because, again, white barely has any
pieces developed. And with our
pieces developed very actively,
there's just no reason
that this sacrifice is going to
work. Bishop takes h six. Here, we
just play G takes H Six, and we can always
bring the king up to G Seven on the
next move to support the H six
pawn. So, of course, now we
play Bishop G four. All right? So bishop G
four. I'm not even really explaining.
Were there any other tempting
squares? Well, perhaps you could say that
Bishop F Five pressures the pawn on Z
Three, but I find the pin to be a
lot more juicy here,
especially because,    um,
by the way, in our previous speedrun
game, in the E four B six speedrun,
I discussed this a little bit. It's a
situation where White actually can't
easily get rid of the pin.
Now, if you move the queen, you allow Bishop
takes F three, ruining the
structure.   If the pond
was not on D three, then White would be able
to slide the Bishop back to E two. This is
a very common technique for
dealing with pins, and it's not the
most active move, but it would allow the
knight to move freely. As it
stands, there's no Bishop E two. So what are
we threatening here with Black? We have a
massive positional threat
here, and perhaps not even
as much a positional threat as a tactical
threat. And that is the typical
move. Knight C six to D
four. We're threatening to jump into D
four or to e five either way.
And either way, White will
be unable to prevent us from
capturing an f three and completely
ruining White's Kingside pawn structure,
which, you know, I'm
sure you've seen or you've
had your share of games where this
happens. And once the pawn structure was
ruined like that on the same side in which
you're castled couple that with
the fact that our dark squared bishop is
aiming right at age two and the
attack is just going to be blistering and
it's going to be unstoppable. And our
opponent has just allowed it. He's played
Queen B three and without a second
thought, we snapped that night off the
board.    But uh, we're going to
have to think carefully after White
recaptures because it's not actually that
easy to figure out a path
forward. Our opponent is thinking.
So maybe our opponent has realized
that, you know, g takes f three is, is
a massive concession and let's see
if he maybe just panics and does something
crazy like not recapture the piece
which you sometimes see. Of course
White should recapture it. I mean,
everything else just loses on the spot.
Now start thinking about what
we're going to do after G takes f three
because I think we can procrastinate a
little bit on the,
uh, more general question of how we're going
to attack. There is a move that we can make
here that's most
definitely not going to hurt. We
know for a fact that this move is not going
to hurt. Now which move am I talking about?
I'm talking about the move knight C six to
D four. And it's important to point out
that if White captures the pawn on b seven,
first of all, we don't really give a damn
about pawns in a position like this. We're
playing for checkmate. But more
specifically, after Queen takes b seven,
notice that you have to move rook A eight
to B eight,   okay?
That dislodges the Queen and
forces it to lose contact with the f
three pawn because all of the squares on
that diagonal are defended by our
knights. So after knights E four,
Queen takes B seven, rugby eight,
queen takes a seven, we
capture the pawn on f three with
a check and then we can follow up, sorry
about that. And then we can follow up
by taking also the pawn on h
two, just fully,
uh,
disrobing the white King. And that just
looks super juicy. We don't have to
calculate any further. And so 94
is a fully justified move.
And in a classical game, I really wouldn't
even calculate past queen B seven, rook B
eight.   Denuding. Denuding
I think is a better word than disrobing.
Although I'm   kind
of happy with my choice, uh,  of words
there as well. So I really
wouldn't calculate past queen takes B seven,
rook B eight. Because worse comes to worst,
we're down a pond and the
pawn on f three is one of the only
ponds that protects White's King. If that
pond disappears, then the
floodgates essentially open. Now, you might
be like, well, what's the pawn on f three
actually doing? Well, for one thing, it's
protecting the G four square. If the pawn
wasn't there. We'd have a Greek gift
sacrifice, actually. And we'd
also have knight f six to G four, followed
by queen H four. So the pawn is making it a
little bit difficult for us, uh, to
worm our way toward the kingside. And
that's why White has to
play queen B three back to D one. That's the
only move to keep the pawn on f
three protected. And again, start thinking,
uh, about what our
next move is going to be after queen D
one. And if Whiteface queen takes P seven,
that'll be a pleasant surprise, and then
everything's going to be really easy. So
let's start discussing
what our attacking techniques are going
to be here and what move
we're going to make, because it's not easy
to find an accurate move after queen D one.
So looking at this, first of all, from a
broad standpoint, what is it that we want
on the kingside? What is our goal?
Well, our goal is pretty
easy to figure out. Our goal is to bring
our queen into the attack. It's going to be
hard to check, mate White just with our
minor pieces. We need to bring our queen,
ideally, to one of two squares,
either h three or h
four. If the queen lands on either of these
squares, it's going to generate
potentially unstoppable mating threats.
H three is really the Golden Square.
That's the square we really want to get. Uh,
that's like Boardwalk and Monopoly,
right? H four is like Park Place,
but there's a couple of squares that we
might also compromise on. Right? What about
h five     or f
five? Okay, well, this is where,
unfortunately,   newer
players, like I said, again and again,
we put a lot of pressure on them, and they
tend to panic in in
ways that, you know,
sometimes make you laugh. But, you
know, everybody is like that when they're
still new to the game. They're just not used
to managing that amount of pressure. Bishop
f seven is a is a flat
out blunder. We just play rook takes f
seven. And this actually makes things
worse for White on the king side,
because now the rook aims at the f three
pawn. So once we move the knight away from f
six, not only does it create the
threat of queen h four, but it
also threatens the pawn on f three. And that
pawn can hardly be defended. So the game is
already over.       They
are there. The game is already over.
And after the game,
we'll discuss a little bit more at length
what, uh, we would have done against
the more resilient queen d one. Okay?
So here we can win in literally a million
ways.    The simplest
move, the business like move, is knight
takes f three, check. But that
actually might not be the best move, which
is, I know, a really weird thing to say, but
remember, our ultimate goal is to get
the queen into the attack.   Which square
in particular? Well, h three, if we
can make that happen. So,
just applying simple logic, what seems to be
a move that we at least have to consider?
Yeah. Well, Queen d seven, right? Queen D
seven is not fancy. It's a utilitarian move,
but it's incredibly powerful.
So after queen D seven, white's
response is forced. The
only way that white can prevent
queen h three is by playing
king G two.   But after
king G two, notice that the f
three pawn becomes even more of a
liability, because if we capture it with our
queen, we capture it with check.
So after queen D seven, king G
two, we basically settle
for a square that's almost as good as h
three. We play the move. What move do we
play? Figure it out. Queen d seven
king G two and this might very well happen
in the game.     Who can
spot the move? Very good. Queen D seven to
f five. Simple chess and
the pawn on f three simply cannot
be defended. We just take on f three and we
made them notice that queen d five doesn't
work because the knight is still on f six.
And it defense d five. We we've managed to
do this without moving the knight away,
which would have also been possible. We
could have played  even a retreating
move like knight d seven would have been
tremendously powerful
here. Some of you were suggesting some fancy
moves, nike four or a sack on h two.
And all of that is totally unnecessary,
uh, if we can play this
in, uh, a more simple way. So, Wendy seven I
really like.    And, uh, I will
remind you at this point that when you're
like up a piece and you're mating your
opponent, there's going to be like seven or
eight winning options in many cases on
every move. And you
shouldn't, you know, you
shouldn't    have the
mentality that, oh, I was coming up with
a different move and Daniel played this
move. And so my move is terrible. Not
necessarily. Right. Your move may have been
an alternative. Now, what's the clinical
way to checkmate the white
king here? There is an order of operations
that has to be adhered to. Remember, our
ultimate goal is to put the queen on h
three. So we can start with a move queen h
three. And you'll notice that that
threatens knight f three and queen takes h
two with checkmate. But if you have a
set of two moves, you should always test
the other move order. I mean, you should
do it as a habit. And
it's easy to establish here. And our
opponent resigns. That night F three check
is actually the more accurate move order.
And I wasn't trying to taunt our opponent, I
was just trying to spell it out. Night F
three check is the actual forced
mate. Because after king G
two, we throw in the preliminary check on
G four, driving the king back, and then we
play queen H three with, of course, the
unstoppable mating construction.
Technically, if you start with queen H
three, white can stave off checkmate
with the move F two, F three.
And of course, now the rook defends the
pawn. Uh, you would still be completely
winning here, obviously, but night F three
is forced mate.  Simple game.
We'll play another one.   But let's go
over a couple of the key points and I'll
talk a little bit about opening theory as
well. So what's funny is when I
did my lessons with Charlie, and those of
you watching on YouTube who don't,
for whom Charlie does not ring a bell,
charlie refers to moist critical.  That's,
uh,   his sort of YouTube and twitch
name.   He is a very
popular YouTuber of millions of subs. And I
coached him for the
Chess.com PogChamps tournament. So all
of my lessons with them are available   on
YouTube, on my YouTube channel. You can
check it out. And I was teaching
Charlie the accelerated
dragon, and most of his opponents
ended up playing the move bishops C four. So
we actually talked a lot about the theory of
bishop C four, even though there's really
no commonly accepted theory,
this move is simply bad. So
it's not like you'll find a lot of stuff in
books about this move, but it's
bad not in the sense that black is
better. It's bad in the sense that it
doesn't fight for an advantage, if that
makes sense. So we played E
six, and I actually think the
move C three isn't all that
bad either.    The, uh,
main line, insofar as we
can call this a main line, is
after White Castle's Kingside. This is what
most people play. What I taught Charlie was
a really interesting idea that involves
playing knight F six. Now,
uh, white is a couple of moves in this
position, we'll look at three, we'll look at
D three to defend the pond,   rookie one
to defend the pond with the rook.
We're actually going to look at four moves.
Knight C three, developing the knight, and
finally the topical move. The principal move
is, of course, E five.
Okay, so after rookie one,
uh, there is a very
nice trick that gives black a super
comfortable position. Who can find
this trick? And I'm going to keep
this deliberately vague. What does
trick mean? Well, you figure it out.
What does black do?   Yeah, it's the center
fork trick. I think the official name for it
is the center fork trick.
And it should ring a bell immediately on,
uh, knight takes C four. This
occurs in a million different ways. It wears
a bunch of different clothes, but it's the
same exact tactic. Anytime there's a
bishop on C four, C five, you take
the pond in the center and then
fork the resulting two pieces
with your pond. And the point of
this exchange is not that it
wins material. It doesn't. White can   give
up the bishop back for the pawn,
but black gets the bishop pair and a tempo
move.   And here,
white also gets a tempo move. Night C
three.   But
according to my analysis, the
queen should jump over to F five.
It's kind of a nice little square where the
queen actually can't really be attacked,
and White can equalize here,
but he needs to be very careful. Black
is very much in the driver's seat with the
bishop pair. The, uh, engine line
is I mean, most people here, I think, would
play D three. And after bishop E
seven, black is already better. The engine
line is D four,   and then
black is supposed to trade on D four. So
takes, takes, takes, takes. Of course,
there's the threat of rook DHS. So we play
bishop E seven. And again,
black is incredibly comfortable here.
Given time, we're going to castle and then
Fee and keto the lightscored bishop and aim
in at the king.   And,
uh, in order to keep
equality, the engine recommends rookie
four, queen E five, rookie four,
queen of five with a repetition. But again,
it's one of those things like, nobody's
actually going to find all of these moves.
So this is the most clinical
line. So that's tricky one.
Now, D three, of course,
avoids the center for a trick knight takes D
four. Makes no sense here. On the other
hand, D three allows us to play, once again
the move D five, much like in the game.
And after the trade,
white should probably put the bishop
on B five to at least create some
pressure against the knight. And here
a great example of
adapting your development to what's going
on in the board. You can play bishop D six,
but I prefer the simpler move, bishop E
seven, to take the sting out of the check on
E one. So after bishop E
seven, if white plays the menacing
looking 95, this is not dangerous at
all. We just play queen C seven.
And again, it looks very
menacing after bishop F four. But if
you look carefully, black as the simple
bishop E seven to D six,
and White's quote unquote
initiative fizzles out. After knight C
six, bishop F four, there's
actually no good discover check, and black
is nearly winning. It's kind
of a cool line.   If you just
look at this carefully, you'll see that the
knight has no good squares. If knight takes
a seven check, we simply
play bishop T seven, and the knight is
trapped. The knight is literally just
trapped in this line. Yeah, white can give a
check. Big deal. We just go king FA. Don't
be afraid to move your king to the side.
Uh,    it's never as
big of a deal as you might think it is.
So this is kind of a cool line, but I'm
getting really bogged down into the details.
Of course, if White doesn't play 95, then
Black Castles and is very comfortable.
So, next line is knight C
three.   And NC three is just
another way to defend the four. And this
allows, once again, the center fork trick in
an even better version, 94, 94, D five.
And if Black plays
Bishop to D three, this is perhaps the
only thing that you have to memorize
out of this entire
analysis here. And I'll show
you guys a very interesting
parallel to a different line.
What is Black's move in this position?
And the fact that I'm already asking you
that question should give you a major hint
about what it's not. Who can
find this move? I'll be impressed.
It's not an easy move to understand. Well,
it kind of is, actually. If you think about
it.
It is c four. Very
nice. So you make the intermezzo,
you attack the bishop. And the point of
this move is simple. If the bishop moves
back to e two, well, then you play D takes E
four, and you're simply up a pawn. Right?
Okay. Well, is there anything else that
White can do? Well, Wynn, try to play Bishop
takes E four and give the bishop up for,
uh, the pond. And in this
case, it's best to actually take
the knight, although taking the bishop is
also okay because this sends the knight back
to e one. That's a
ridiculously passive square. And after
Bishop D, we
can just continue developing. And black is
much better. Notice that White pays
the price for the placement of this knife. D
takes E four, runs into Bishop takes
H Two, and the queen is lost because
there's no contact between the rook and the
queen. So, at any rate,
all of these moves are very subpar.
And e five is also subpar. It's just what
most people play. And here, the knight
jumps into G four,
attacking the pawn from the other
side.   And when White plays
rookie One, black breaks up the
pawn with the simple move D
six. This is what I showed Charlie. E
takes D six, is forced. We play. Bishop
takes D six. And for
example, after H three, Ni G
goes back to e five.
Black has a very comfortable position.
We have better control of the center.
Excellent minor pieces. And after bishop
B five, we just play bishop D. Seven. And
these lines I'm going through very fast
because they're simple, they're easy to
follow. And I will conclude
this little opening overview with
one beautiful trick. If White
tries to break free in the center with D
four, who can tell me
the winning line? After CD, queen
takes D four. And if you're. Tactically
sharp. You should find this almost
instantly. You should identify the theme
immediately, and it might take you a second
to figure out the logistics of it.
Very good. I'd, uh, have
three preliminary move
to open up the bishop. And
after GF three, we throw in another check
on H two, winning the queen.     Yeah,
opponents hate this one simple trick.
So hopefully everything made sense here.
Again, the point of the speedrun. This is an
opening theme speedrun. So I am going to do
a good amount of this type of opening
analysis. I hope it's not too dry.
Um, I am really trying
to help people learn a full
repertoire. Like, my goal is that by the end
of this speedrun, you will have if you watch
it diligently and you supplement it with
your own learning,   you're going to have
a full  opening
repertoire that you can just apply. Right?
This is for people who just are kind of
looking to start from scratch and kind of
want guidance about what to play.
So, yes, there's
going to be a fair amount of dry
opening analysis, and I deviate from a
lot of other coaches in that I
tell my students that you have to
do a rather
substantial, uh,
amount of memorization, even as a
beginner, if you really want to learn
openings properly. I hate the whole
idea, which is spread by a lot
of chess authors and
coaches that like, oh, there's a
way to learn openings where you don't have
to memorize a single line. And when you're a
beginner, you should stay away from
memorization BS. There is a
fear of memorization
among the opening
levels, which you shouldn't have. You
really should try to memorize a good amount
of theory. Now, you can memorize and
understand at the same time. You can
memorize the move, but also understand
why it's played. Right. So, knight F
six, you can remember this move, but say,
hey, I get why this move is made. We're
trying to orchestrate the center fork trick
with knight 64. So, a little
bit of a tangent, but remember that
it's okay to learn opening
files with the aim of memorizing
moves. Some moves, some just have to be
memorized.  Um, so you're trying to
strike the balance between the two.
Um, the ideas behind the moves are
also very important. So hopefully
this made sense. We go
back to  this position.
Move four. Our opponent plays a very rare
move and allows us to immediately strike in
the center   with D five.
So already we've solved all of our opening
problems, and I think black is the only one
who can realistically be better here. So
takes takes Bishop back to B
three. Uh, bishop bishop B five
is what I expected.
And here we were planning to play
bishop D six,   uh,
castles. And like I mentioned, the
knight very often comes out to E
seven in order to take the sting out
of this bishop   and to
take the sting out of the check. And this is
a very sort of compact
form, uh,   of development.
Black's got a great position. I forgot
to mention one thing. I mentioned
that I'd show you a parallel,
uh, with this C four move that we just
looked at. So, in the English in these four
nights English, there is a
line    which I often
play in blitz E two, E four, and
Black responds with bishop C five. White
initiates the center fork trick with knight
65.    And a ton
of players, including a ton of
grandmasters in this position,
play the erroneous Bishop back
to D six. This is
ridiculously common. And what's amazing is
that White's already winning after the
next move. And I won't ask you for the
next move. Hopefully, you've been paying
attention. The move is not D tape C five,
but rather C five. It's the
same exact concept. What
black's position just falls apart.
Either you drop the bishop and your pawn
structure is ruined, or you have to move the
bishop, and your night has to go back to G
eight. And this really   deserves
no further comment after bishop C four and
Lake queen D five game, uh, is already over.
I've won a ton of games like
this.     So another
idea to file into your mental rolodex.
But in any case,
white plays bishop B three. So here we, uh,
amend our opening strategy with knight F
six. And C four
is definitely a very weird move. It's
not a terrible move, but
we're very much spoiled for choice after
this move. So a lot of you here
were proposing this move, queen E seven.
Check. Which, honestly, I didn't even
consider. I can see that it's the top engine
move. I do see that. Uh, but this is a bit
of a weird move. And the reason I didn't
consider it is because of queen E two. I
figured a queen trade isn't really in Black
savor. And I guess I'm wrong. And the reason
I'm wrong is for very concrete
reasons, because after the queen trade,
black has an absolutely devastating move.
And this is a development move. But it
leads to an initiative that
bases, uh,   itself on the
weakness of the D four square
and the fact that White is so undeveloped.
What's this move? What move am I referring
to here?   Yeah, it's just bishop
C eight to G four. And it's a very simple
move. And after c takes d
five nd four. Check.
White's position just crumbles. It
falls apart. You have nowhere good to go
with your king. King f one is
forced.  And after knight takes
B three, AB 95. Just look at
White's pawn structure. Look at white's weak
squares. We can also take on F three. It's,
like, minus three. So this would, in fact,
have been the most effective way to punish
C four, queen E seven. White
can also play king F one. Of course.
But then, then
we'll take and we'll get the bishop
out and we'll castle queenside,
and we'll have another, like, raging
initiative against Black, white's king.
So that doesn't solve any problems either.
We played DC in bishop D six, which I would
argue is a very, uh, straightforward
and simple way to gain the
advantage.  So after bishop
D six, castles, castles. Let me
just reiterate that D four in this
position would have, in fact solved all
of White's problems   were it
not for the very concrete trick. Bishop
takes h two. And if you're a beginner
against, a very important idea just to
remember. And so our opponent
plays D three. And here we
decided on the simple H six
to prevent bishop G five. White
plays Knight c three. And
frankly, I think knight C three might be the
decisive mistake. I think this move already
allows an unstoppable
problem of 94 and bishop takes F
three. So the reality is that White
had to play H three here to stay in the
game.   But after bishop F
five, black's advantage
is long term and it's indisputable.
White's position is
really miserable with his backward pawn on
Z three. And let's say White plays knight Z
three, black is a lot of possibilities. I
like to move queen D seven trying to sack on
H three. And for us, the sacrifice is a
lot more realistic because we've got other
pieces aiming at the kingside.
Um, so my name is
Chico. Asks a question about a little
bit earlier. Let me rewind. So my
name is Chico. You're asking about D four,
but remember that in this position, there is
a bishop on C four that's blocking the
queen's access to that square. You were
saying, why not bishop before check, queen
takes before it's? Because this bishop is in
the way. Okay? So once I played these moves
on the board, you should see that.    All
right?    But, uh, good to
clarify. So after bishop G
four already,
White's position is dire. And I
should point out that after H three,
bishop H,
which would be a typical way
of dealing with the spin, we automatically
and here really automatically take on G
four. Here, the sacrifice should be totally
automatic for you because you already know
that black has the unstoppable twin threats
of 94 and 95. You can stop one of
them, but not both. You can play bishop E
three or you can play rookie one. But in
either case, we put the knight on just the
other square and we either win the knight on
F three with Mate, or we win the queen on D
one. So it's just very obvious
that there's no defense here.
And, uh, I don't know what White should have
done, but I think the position is nearly
hopeless. This makes it even worse.
We take it, we go
94. And the last point
of discussion is, what would we have
done after queen to d
one.   Again, many
paths lead to Rome here, but the
move that I was planning is
actually not queen d seven. So here the
circumstances have changed. After queen d
seven, king g two. Remember that in the
game, we had this move, queen f five. Now,
we can still play this, but we're not
attacking f three anymore, so it's not
quite as effective. And White has a
tempo to bring in defensive
forces, which can really
douse the flames of the attack pretty
quickly. So I think the best move is to
take a slightly different path and go night
h five.    Now, the
threat is queen h four, and the obvious
defensive move here is 94.
But I think a crucial point is
that we can play queen h four
anyway.     Now, this
seems to drop a bishop, but who
can tell me what the subtlety is?
How does black proceed in this position?
And having familiarized yourself with
all of the attacking ideas, this should be
really easy.
So where does
black go? If you're on YouTube,
obviously pause, figure it out.
So it's not night f four because
of just bishop takes f four.
You're attracted to
this made threat, but you're forgetting the
bishop can just take the night. So
the move is queen h three.   It's
subtle and it's deadly. It threatens knight
takes f three. Right, that makes sense.
White has to play bishop d five, but now
these pieces are
aligned. Chess is insane, and we just go
rook 88, and we win back
at least one of the pieces. But
more importantly, this is just a rook lift.
Like, the point is not to take the night.
The point is to go to G six and just
checkmate the white king. Notice, uh,  that
bishop f four here not possible because of
the night on h five. So that's actually why
we need the night there to control the f
four square. But you can also do this
intuitive. You don't have to see that to
play night h five. It's clear that we want
the knight somewhere on the kingside.
Okay, so this is virtually
forced. The engine move is f four.
And here, even better than knight takes f
four, is just to bring the queen in any way.
And it's like minus four. I mean, we're
about to take on f four. That's all she
wrote. So queen d one would not have
saved White, but our opponent gives up the
piece and allows   immediate, uh,
immediate checkmate. I remind you that the
move here is knight f three. Check. And then
queen g four, queen h three, as necessary
with mate. So, a simple game,
a straightforward game, but I thought we had
a fruitful discussion of
the, uh,  sort of
Sicilian or Italian against the Sicilian
line. And, uh,  you
basically never have to learn it again if
you just remember a couple of these lines.